pourquoi vous nettoyez la table
j'en ai vu quelques-uns le faire aussi
quand il s'embarras ça c'est signe
d'embarrassant d'être en face de vous
vous allez tomber le masque ce soir vous
avez envie
mais je sais ce que vous allez me
demander de faire je vous ai pas je ne
vous ai pas oublié
je suis stressé surtout avec les femmes
ah bon et plus avec les femmes qu'avec
les hommes pourquoi pas beaucoup
d'hommes en fait vous obéissez aux
femmes comme vous obéissez pratiquement
votre mère puisqu'on a compris en tout
cas vous avez une relation forte à votre
mère
mais j'ai une relation forte avec les
femmes
ça veut dire quoi une relation forte aux
elles incarnent une chose importante
quoi
c'est tout
j'aime bien les femmes
ça vous l'avez toujours dit conversation
physiquement tout ils ont tout elles ont
tout
elles ont tout elles ont l'intelligence
elles ont le corps c'est quand même
riche comme projet quand même aller très
vite
sexuellement comme vous voulez qu'est-ce
que j'aime bien
mais j'adore quand je suis insulté non
je sais pas je sais pas mais j'aime bien
les femmes autoritaires mais oui c'est
ce qui me semblait dans votre vie avec
les femmes c'est toujours mieux c'est
toujours sexué si c'est pas sexuel c'est
un peu rasoir vous avez toujours
toujours voulu séduire les femmes et les
hommes la séduction c'est votre
c'est quoi
j'ai complètement guéri je déteste les
gens fébril pathétiques dans le besoin
du regard de l'autre constamment j'ai eu
ça mais j'ai guéri un peu ça si vous ne
m'aimez pas je m'en sortir ai
qui moi vous parlez de moi
non mais je veux dire je ne dépends pas
uniquement de regard de l'autre beaucoup
mais pas uniquement j'ai une petite
constitution d'autonomie légère mais
j'en ai une petite constitution est-ce
que pour vous justement séduire veut
dire être aimé est-ce que quand vous
séduisez vous pensez du coup vous êtes
aimé
ah mais je suis pas sûr de l'avoir envie
d'être aimé c'est bien ce qui me
semblait
puisque c'est très embarrassant d'être
aimé
sur tous les hommes et les femmes
s'aiment pas bien dans mon spectacle ça
parle que de ça quand je parle des
fragments des histoires amoureux de
Roland Bart au théâtre le soir et que il
parle de la ration amoureuse on voit
bien que c'est atroce qui a aucun
rapport à l'autre dans l'amour enfin
c'est très compliqué l'amour n'est pas
obligatoirement le respect de l'autre
l'amour est un fantasme une projection
une cristallisation
donc cet entretien je me suis aperçue
que je ne savais finalement rien de vous
parce que vous ne dites rien c'est vrai
que vous préservez votre votre vie
privée j'ai appris que vous aviez une
fille donc de 26 ans Emma
je ne savais même pas que vous étiez
père
bah oui je suis père ouais et vous
n'avez jamais vécu en couple un petit
peu de temps en temps très très peu
pourquoi qu'est-ce qui est difficile
dans la vie de couple Fabrice les femmes
ne vous supportent pas ou c'est vous qui
les supportez pas
c'est être un couple c'est pas pour dire
une phrase mais je vais quand même la
faire vous me l'attendez c'est ne faire
qu'un mais lequel c'est pas de moi
vous nettoyez la table
ça c'est signe d'embarras
c'est assez embarrassant d'être en face
de vous oui parce qu'on est touché on
est séduit et puis en même temps on se
dit oh là là on est pas dans ses repères
habituel mais c'est bien ça
alors justement je continue puisqu'on a
on a commencé avec les femmes je pensais
parler de votre enfant puisque on a pris
aussi beaucoup de choses mais les femmes
il paraît qu'elle vaut à vos débuts
d'ailleurs un agent de renom vous a dit
je ne suis pas sûr que la carrière
cinématographique soit pour toi tu n'es
pas sexuée c'est vrai qu'en vrai
c'était à l'agent le plus connu en
France ça vous êtes pas un mec qui vous
dit qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de toi
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de toi le
problème tu sais Fabrice
on sait pas si tu es au mot on sait pas
si t'es pas sexué
ça m'a accablé pendant 15 ans
[Musique]
avec les femmes
et après j'ai eu j'ai eu la chance de
faire la discrète qui me donnait un rôle
un tout petit peu plus c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas le cowboy énorme couillu
et tout mais j'avais des rôles avec
Robert de confident j'étais un peu bon
c'était compliqué j'avais peut-être pas
dû trouver ma ma libido mais je l'ai
trouvé depuis elle était énorme mal
libido
je vous parle pas de on a bien compris
ma consommation est importante aussi
juste avant en effet à débat arrêtez de
lui mais sur la prostitution
que vous connaissez bien de manière
différente des autres gens c'est à dire
j'ai été beaucoup par curiosité
pratiquée la les femmes les filles les
femmes dont le métier parce que d'abord
j'avais une curiosité immense sur la
sexualité et un jour un jour pendant que
j'étais coursier
un collègue m'a dit tu devrais aller à
la Goutte d'Or ça te coûterait beaucoup
moins cher parce que il y a des bordels
et qui sont malheureusement fermés
depuis
et là le prix est vraiment intéressant
alors je me précipite à la Goutte d'Or
et je vois des bordels beaucoup de gens
émigrés beaucoup de gens devant la porte
j'avais vu ça dans mon enfance mais je
comprenais pas ce qu'il faisait à
attendre devant des potes il y avait un
Judas
et j'ouvre le judas d'abord je mets au
moins une trentaine de minutes pour
m'approcher et on a bien compris que la
femme qui devient que le corps de la
femme comme marchandise est une
abomination on le sait tout ça mais le
corps du malheureux pitoyable qui est
dans les rues ou qui reste trois heures
n'est pas brillant non plus alors tout
ça c'est assez complexe et là j'ai
ouvert le judaï j'ai entendu une femme
il y en avait 7 8 des jolies des un peu
bizarres et j'entends 32 les hommes
bouger je dis mais pourquoi elle dit 32
les hommes bougés et au bout d'une
demi-heure je comprends que 32 était le
prix de la passe et bougez voulait dire
décidément il y en a marre jusqu'au
moment où il y en a une qui a ouvert la
porte une femme très plantureuse pleine
de puissance et à la ouvert la porte et
elle a dit tu attends Brigitte Bardot et
le pauvre émigré il a fait non j'attends
pas Brigitte Bardot Brigitte Bardot
alors il fait non et ben elle est pas là
c'est moi qui la remplace alors tu te
décides et le pauvre gars dit oui oui et
je suis rentré avec lui j'en ai profité
et je me retourne dans un bordel pour
Jean modeste j'avais connu la Madeleine
à 400 francs j'avais connu le le la rue
Blondel à 250 francs je rencontrais tous
les mecs qu'on connaît de télé etc il y
a rien de plus déprimant que d'aller
chez les [__] je vous dis tout jeune
je l'ai fait pendant une quinzaine
d'années donc je l'ai arrêté depuis une
vingtaine d'années mais il y a rien de
plus triste quand tu rentres à bon tes
pommes de terre au fond du sac donc tu
es un peu à bout mais quand tu quand tu
sors quand tu sors Mireille ah quand tu
sors mais tu es déprimé mais déprimé
c'est prodigieux là tu vas au fond c'est
un film de face binder à la sortie
de temps en temps de temps en temps dans
ces endroits comme la goutte d'eau
c'était très populaire et où on
entendait du rythmen blues tout ça et ça
pouvait être gay quand je vous écoute
quand même dans cette dans cette
recherche on va dire assidu forcené de
la femme et de tout ça qui m'intéresse
c'est d'une petite partie de ma vie j'ai
bien compris mais si j'écoute ce que
vous ce que vous dites on a quand même
le sentiment pendant que des années que
vous n'avez pas voulu aimer ou pu aimer
qui sont les femmes de votre vie votre
mère
ce qui est quand même ça je pense que il
y a quelque chose d'important
ce n'est pas une maman italienne puisque
c'est votre père qui italiens on dirait
une maman italienne elle prend une place
importante c'est de l'amour de votre vie
il y avait d'ailleurs dans le reportage
quelqu'un du quartier qui disait que
vous y alliez tout le temps que vous
portiez même le linge un peu de temps en
temps pas tous les jours mais de temps
en temps petit sac de linge
donc vous êtes avant tout un fils ah oui
je suis pas un mari
je crois que je commence à le comprendre
je suis sympa je peux faire des
promenades je peux dire des textes à
l'oreille je suis pas un mari et un père
vers la fin j'ai été un père pas trop
mal vers la fin je veux dire après
l'adolescence quoi disons vers 15h vers
14 15 ans j'ai pas été si mal ah voilà
voilà tous les deux
et vous avez appris à devenir père ou
l'être devenu maintenant ou c'est plutôt
une amie
de la même manière que ma mère je l'aime
pas parce que c'est ma mère c'est parce
que c'est cette femme j'aime ma fille
évidemment filialement mais parce que ce
qu'elle est et et
admirable qu'est-ce qu'elle a comme
qualité d'ailleurs votre fille
résister déjà à m'avoir comme père c'est
pas mal à la résister et à un parcours
qui ressemble un peu au mien elle a pas
été à l'école longtemps et et
elle a une perception elle me fait
énormément rire quand elle raconte des
choses c'est irrésistible et votre mère
qu'est-ce qu'elle a comme qualité
qu'est-ce qu'elle vous a donné Fabrice
alors ma mère c'est tout ma mère pour
moi si je suis comédien c'est grâce à
elle parce qu'elle est comédienne
c'est une identité d'une richesse d'une
intelligence extrême c'est à dire
qu'elle a pas été du tout à l'école elle
était à l'Assistance publique tout ça
tout ça et elle a été placée chez des
gens tout ça femme de ménage pendant le
ménage au Figaro en plus pendant 20 ans
peut-être tous les comédiens racontent
qu'ils ont toujours des parents immigrés
qu'il y a toujours eu des femmes de
ménage et ça c'est un gros tout des
acteurs
du magasin
quand les parents étaient dans dans un
gros problème financier après après
le ménage vous êtes un nostalgique de
l'enfance
ça doit être plus fort que ça
complètement écorché d'avoir de ne plus
être enfant alors ça doit être
de l'ordre enfin ça doit être de l'ordre
je serai pas répondre du traumatisme
envie d'être finalement encore presque
dans
dans les bras de votre mère même dans le
ventre de votre mort envie de retourner
carrément
non non pas du tout c'est pour être
imprégné par cette extrême sensibilité
qu'on que qu'incarne l'enfance et que
l'on entend donc c'est vrai que barreau
a été un homme extrêmement important il
a été le premier prêtre ouvrier et les
gens dont ils parlent étaient des vrais
cas sociaux admirables mais dans ces
bandes de voyou il y avait un vrai
climat de misère qui avait la
prostitution il y avait des gens en
prison il y avait des crimes et donc
c'était des gens très très méchants des
gens qui étaient l'âge ils avaient entre
16 et 25 ans et vous et moi j'avais 13
ans 14 15 ans vous avez arrêté l'école
oui qu'est-ce que vous faisiez dans la
rue ou à cet âge-là et pourquoi vous
avez arrêté l'école si tôt à 12-13 ans
j'étais très mauvais donc on m'a mis ma
maman ma mère m'a mis dans le salon de
coiffure on connaît l'histoire par cœur
à 14 ans je vais même pas 14 ans quand
je suis rentré dans le salon de coiffure
et de 14 à 18 ans je c'était une époque
merveilleuse c'était les hippies il y
avait des pétards partout et il y avait
plusieurs groupes il y avait des
intellectuels dans un certain coin de la
butte donc j'ai été dans une exploration
obsédante tous les milieux là c'est
d'ailleurs ça à la prostitution n'est
résulte la prostitution le fait le
problème des femmes qui avec qui on
monte c'est un truc qui est assez beau
si on les respecte mais c'était aussi la
curiosité se promener partout donc je me
promenais dans plusieurs milieux et ça
ça a été mon obsession comme j'ai été
coursier très longtemps et que je
livrais des plats chauds chez les riches
et les pauvres chez les [__] ça
c'est devenu un matériau c'est là que
j'ai rencontré Michel Berger France Gall
j'ai apporté des pizzas et j'ai vu
France Gall et Michel Berger j'ai livré
même pas un film ils étaient en couple
ils étaient très étranges
vous fasciner
dans l'appartement bradsupratsu
c'est très bizarre
le couple est une chose fascinante c'est
pour les autres aussi on indique aux
autres qu'on est ensemble
ça peut pas fonctionner dans le face à
face sans les amis d'où l' horreur des
couples en amis en vacances ce qui est
horrible dans le couple c'est que plus
personne n'est sexualisé on va chez qui
on va chez les Intel tu sais qui se
passera rien il se passera rien on va en
couple la lumière on bouffe qu'est-ce
que tu as vu dernièrement alors là moi
je meurs là qu'est-ce que tu as vu au
cinéma là je peux je déteste pourtant
vous avez un modèle de couple en face de
vous parents
non non lui il est pas doué du tout pour
être ami un mari ni un non non non parce
que ce structure dans le couple beaucoup
beaucoup de souffrance mais qui est
structurant on parle de sujets très
sérieux vous savez c'est immense le
problème du couple le couple dans le
mauvais côté c'est pour se fuir soit
c'est-à-dire l'individu totalement
incomplet cherche dans l'autre la
complétive c'est-à-dire qu'en gros un
couple ces deux individus pas fini qui
inventent un troisième individu couple
alors ils savent pas qu'ils sont mais
ils sont quelqu'un mais qui sent le
couple donc c'est 1 + 1 qui fait un 3
c'est le 3 ce E2 et quand ils disent
cette phrase terrifiante oh ben nous on
a décidé de plus aller au Maroc hein
vous savez les femmes elles font des
choses comme ça oh ben nous on a décidé
vous pouvez rester deux entités vraiment
deux individus mais c'est très rare
c'est très rare c'est quand les gens
disent moi non pas du tout Émile Maroc
pas vrai Léon alors Léon il est dans les
bidons il est en train il bricole le
mari souvent il dit quoi ah t'as pas
aimé le Maroc non j'ai pas aimé bon
évidemment c'est une idée un peu minable
il y a le couple sublime il y a le
couple Sartre Simone de Beauvoir ça ça
de la gueule mais il y a le couple
fusionnel qui est intéressant il y a le
couple normal comment tu vas chérie tu
as fait les courses je redescends ça
peut être magnifique je ne juge aucun
couple je pense qu'il y a pas de
solutions
va chercher le pain jamais à part ma
mère personne m'a dit va chercher le
pain je crois que moi je crois que j'ai
compris une chose quand même le vrai
couple vous pouvez votre mère écoute
Mireille je vais vous tutoie je vous je
pense que vous avez été d'une intuition
fulgurante en pensant que c'est ma maman
on ne peut pas lutter contre votre mère
franchement Fabrice elle n'est pas elle
n'est pas là non d'accord mais la femme
qui va lutter contre votre mère je crois
pas du tout écouter c'est énorme quand
même c'est magnifique
je dis que c'est du boulot le désir 20
ans après comment ils se remonte dessus
c'est du boulot c'est du travail
de la libido 20 piges qui connaissent
tout non mais attendez ça c'est une
vision négative mais la vision positive
c'est échapper à la solitude il y a rien
de plus déprimant que d'être seul le
couple c'est quand même la solution pour
pas être seul ce que j'essaye de vous
dire c'est que le couple référentiel
qu'on admire est un lieu de revanche est
un lieu d'animosité ce n'est pas un lieu
béni ça n'est pas vrai c'est un lieu de
frustration c'est un lieu d'animosité
c'est un lieu de c'est un lieu qui peut
être minable ou grandiose ou qui peut
être quotidien je ne le lise c'est un
texte c'est c'est passionnant le couple
on peut pas le réduire c'est un problème
qui me fascine ce que j'ai appris avec
la maturité je vais tout vous dire là je
vais lâcher le gros truc c'est un gros
truc que je vais lâcher les gens hyper
prêt je suis homo je vis avec un homme
politique non
je vais vous dire un gros truc
si je vivais en couple j'attendrai
tellement d'être sauvé par l'autre
car si je viens en couple faut qu'il me
sauve
faut qu'il fasse que la vie soit
supportable faut que je sois plus
déprimer faut que je sois plus un
individu je veux qu'il m'enlève de moi
je veux que allemand lève de moi je
calme sorte de moi je veux plus
supporter plus rien je veux qu'elle me
fasse un miracle pour qu'elle soit
miraculeuse je parle même pas
physiquement mais viens jamais
miraculeuse faut qu'elle me sorte de moi
ça c'est pas possible personne peut te
sortir de toi mais ce que je vais finir
vous dire parce que vous me sortez sur
un truc très très passionnant le mec
très névrosé qui nettoie la table mais
ce que je veux vous dire c'est que quand
j'ai compris que
on pourrait pas
vivre à ma place
car ce que j'attendais moi c'est qu'on
vit moi je vais tout vous raconter on va
y aller moi j'ai une histoire il y a
quelques années une trentaine d'années
moi j'ai fait un projet avec une femme
gère pas un studio tout en blanc j'ai
peint le studio
elle est partie loin pour réfléchir sur
ce mec un peu bizarre qui était amoureux
d'elle c'est très longtemps
le studio allez rentrer j'avais préparé
des petites assiettes j'ai presque mis
des bougies tiens très longtemps j'ai
appris à manger elle les boules ça
commence à lui prendre dès le début du
dîner elle s'est dit il est en train de
s'inventer un drôle de truc j'étais là
tu es contente je suis contente je
voulais un petit projet un bon petit
projet pépère et bon petit truc bien
régressif bien bien régressif et un
moment j'ai été dans le pieu et là elle
en a pas elle a dit mais c'est quoi ton
projet là tu es dans quel scénario je
dis un scénario normal quoi et là elle a
dit je crois que tu t'es complètement
planté moi ce qui m'angoisse dans les
histoires d'amour c'est quand les gens
se racontent des scénarios qui sont pas
traumatisés
en pleine figure
à ce moment là sinon
je voudrais vous dire autre chose plus
importante quand vous dites j'attends
d'une femme qu'elle me sorte de moi-même
qu'elle pratiquement qu'elle me sauve de
moi elle m'a dit quoi non mais j'ai
l'impression que vous passiez votre
temps à vous fuir et vous dites
effectivement ma vie met un supportable
et c'est pour ça que vous êtes comédien
aussi c'est pour ça que vous êtes allé
voir dans tous les milieux c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs c'était formidable moi j'ai
noté qu'à un moment donné vous dites je
n'en reviens pas de jouer avec deux par
Dieu Marielle bouquet je n'en reviens
pas qu'on m'est accepté je n'en reviens
pas d'avoir échappé à ma classe vous
l'avez dit c'est sans arrêt échappé qui
a été qui était artiste pour vous êtes
venus en face de moi faut bien que je
fasse du Mirail d'humain
échapper échapper c'est votre mot
échapper quand même
échapper à sa classe échapper à soi
mais c'est l'envie tous hein qui est
plus ou moins aigu en fonction du
mal-être et de l'angoisse qu'on vit en
fait vous êtes étonnamment angoissé
mais j'en parle pas aux gens et je les
embête pas c'est ça que j'ai acquis
ça c'est vraiment ça que que l'analyse
apporte c'est que j'accable pas les gens
avec le paquet le paquet je le garde
pour moi cela dit après 30 ans de
psychanalyse on peut se dire que c'est
déjà costaud 30 ans de psychanalyse
c'est vrai bah c'est normal dis donc on
va dans les sables mouvants faut être
solide quand vous êtes sur scène
l'angoisse n'existe plus
ben quand on est sur scène on est
concentré il s'est un très gros travail
donc on s'occupe beaucoup du travail
voilà parce que comme vous réciter des
textes je pense à carte blanche notre
spectacle
voilà entre autres entre autres
formidable voilà et ça c'est vraiment
votre vie et d'ailleurs j'aimerais
savoir ce que vous citez en permanence
c'est complètement dingue ce que vous
avez appris vous passez votre temps à
prendre Fabrice c'est une connerie je
déteste les gens qui vous le faites
parce qu'il y a rien de plus beau quand
vous commencez un spectacle en disant la
plupart des hommes ont de la poésie une
idée si vague que ce vague même de leur
idée pour eux la définition de la poésie
c'est ça qui m'a donné envie de faire ce
spectacle c'est magnifique qu'est-ce que
tu veux dire avec tes propres mots
peut-être vous avez envie de réciter
quelques verres non
si vous me preniez dans vos bras
le mec complètement pitoyable si vous
prenez un grand moment si vous me prenez
dans vos bras
ça serait pas plus mal c'est pas que je
voudrais vous imposer ça mais attendez
on va peut-être pas j'ai peut-être on va
peut-être se dire en revanche je vous
embrasse ça vous va pour vous dire au
revoir je vais être ridicule là je veux
dire par là que
attendez non mais donnez-moi juste une
seconde pour terminer cette affaire
c'est vous qui voulez
pas à finir j'aime pas du tout que ça
finisse moi mais je suis pas je suis pas
non plus pitoyable genre il y a plus de
lumière je n'existe plus je vais aller
vers la fin de l'émission alors tant
qu'on y va je vous embrasse je vous
embrasse à défaut de vous prendre dans
mes bras vas-y mais vous en faites
souvent des comme ça vous mais non
jamais c'est la première fois c'est une
première merci
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]